so great with awesome lift in mauston  they were doing that take me or leave me  and and I interrupted them  the powerhouse vocalist surprised fans  thursday night at New York gay bar  industry by singing her new single queen  of swords you must take my passion for  anger inside it was a great crowd and it  was just perfect the 45 year-old let it  go singer is set to release her  self-titled album adina on September  23rd her first since divorcing from  actor Taye Diggs and once she says is  very personal before her surprise  performance Adina gushed about her loyal  fans all the most amazing diva  incredible iconic women have been  embraced by a gay audience so for me to  be embraced by that audience and to have  been supported for so many years ever  since I was in rent through wicked and  everything is just for me it's actually  one of the things I'm most proud of  I'm like the queen of